that might come I'm offensively crying
yeah yeah but it looks like cinematic
and kind of beautiful it actually is
everybody
no one knows anything you're your own
person
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Lewis Capaldi he's
a grammy-nominated multi-platinum
singer-songwriter who just released his
long-awaited sophomore album It's called
broken by desire to be Heavenly Sent the
latest single is wish you the best check
out the video and bring a box of tissues
Louis Capaldi welcome to the show hello
I'm navis well there's no need to be
nervous no need to be nervous how are
you around spicy food before we get
started I know I think you're the first
Scottish palette that we put to the test
yes first Scottish person on here feels
good
um I feel like I'm gonna let a nation
down here but yeah I'm good I've already
taken us what I feel will be my last
sort of
um
bearable [__] today did you do it here
I've done it here oh amazing yeah a shot
here who else is I was just thinking
maybe Jake gyllenha was taking a dump in
here this is beautiful
[Music]
next one here we go
it's delightful
[Music]
dive a little sauce we're on the way
sometimes people come on take a bite oh
sorry I was just I was just enjoy I feel
like we were on a date there and I was
just enjoying we are on a date yeah we
can think about that yeah of course you
just took some more I don't know I know
I know that was kind of just an Impulse
okay I'm not trying to show off over
here
I don't think I'll eat all of them all
the time
but while they're in this sort of
comfortable Zone yeah we'll take big
swings there we go
so as I know you're aware there's a
current Tick-Tock trend of people in
tears warning others against watching
your new music video for wish you the
best as it's a one-way ticket to crying
your face off yeah R.I.P to John and
Willow what's been your reaction to the
reaction because from your Duets it
would seem like you'd get some sort of
sick pleasure out of watching your fans
cry yeah I enjoy it I think what's
nicest
I've always wanted to be viable on Tech
talk I've always wanted to do about
anything there I never thought I would
get there by traumatizing children
but
if that's paying the bells then so be it
but yeah it's good man I'm I'm just like
I like to see people suffering that's
what I'm trying to say and this is well
me too me too you know yeah I often
should I say not to talk about [__]
too much I often think about your
[__] you do yeah I'll think that poor
thing you put it through so much and I
wonder like I was thinking maybe like
it's like at the Battle of the song down
there but I think actually it must be
pristine actually it's closer to
pristine than the former yes you know
what I mean I'm battle tested upkeep
you're like sort of taken care of it
that no one else does and uh yeah but
it's I just often I say a prayer every
time I go to watch one of these well
thank you for praying for me yeah thank
you for praying for me are you ready to
move on here to Sauce number two a
[__] guess so so this next one
we've got the cree Verde here in the two
spot
what's next
hello zesty
[Music]
I'm a DJ Khaled like topped out
by the way I'm gonna be a [__] mess
by the end Let's Go Let it Fly does
anyone just see what happens then you
just not eat the wings and talk yeah
kinda that's when from like my
perspective I gotta think I'm Gonna Fly
a little bit yeah you know what I mean
because somebody's like disengaging from
the thing but then you have to like
that's that's when the format of the
show becomes a challenge for the host of
the show yeah and then it just the whole
thing is yeah you just checked DJ called
the [__] out of here should have said
less than you if you don't eat your food
[__] off yeah yeah no that's mental
freeze pray wild so I think but that's
lovely I love that there we go
so I understand that you began
performing at 11 years old doing pubs
throughout the UK where you'd often hide
in the bathroom before the show to avoid
getting kicked out for being underage
what was the significance of the Grange
bar and fold house at that time in your
young career wow [__] hell you need
to do one of these with nodules the
[__] the king like the two kings at
it you know what I mean but um yeah no
The Grange was good we did some like
Cabo's gigs in there my friend Adam
Warrington who plays guitar now for
young blood which is quite interesting
but no one gave a [__] no one gave a
[__] about me and Adam playing they hate
they actually disliked us playing kicks
yeah did you ever have to deal with
hecklers in a pub environment yeah all
the time like all wins they need to be
home early for school and [__] just
you look like a piece of [__] because we
were coming on and try to sing new songs
like the weed written and stuff and I
think people just wanted to dance which
I have no I totally understand but
um Who's Laughing Now
[__] you but it was great it was great
for undergrades I used to be all by my
friend David who um Stephen Barry and
they they were they were great they used
to always let us in
they don't own the pub now so I can see
this but we were under the age and we
were able to come in like they would let
us play do you know what I mean so yeah
yeah great stuff well shout out to them
the police are coming to your house now
[__]
foreign
yeah
I said you're loving man yeah right and
we're shifting gears on you it's coming
at you from all animals over here you're
teasing me a little bit right yeah we
don't want you to be comfortable over
here no I like it that's lovely that
so I love your quote about songwriting
where you dispelled the myth that the
best records come the easiest saying the
best songs come from me sitting at a
piano bashing my head against a brick
wall for hours on end to get one good
Melody what's the longest length of time
you've ever taken to write a song from
beginning to end I mean there's ones I'm
still not finished that I don't think
I'll ever get finished but like someone
you loved was I started on August 2018.
and finished it and like September 2019
so you're talking no sorry about 17 to
October 2017 and then finished it in
like September 2018 just a few months
before it came out so it's almost like a
year to write the one song yeah I should
have said a year
[Laughter]
songwriting for me is like people say
it's like catharsis and all the rest of
it it's a beautiful thing but catharsis
isn't always comfortable or enjoyable do
you know what I mean right I think um I
spend most of my time hating myself when
I'm writing songs or um and yeah and I
think that's fine I think that's what
gets that's my process
um but um yeah I just um I subject the
general public to the pain of listening
to my music so oh I feel like I should
have to suffer as well
[Music]
barbecue
not too much of a kid but it's usually a
kick a kick spot I feel like this is the
first sauce that takes a jump that's
more than just one step you know
but look at you
clean in the wing clean in the wind [__]
you hey Judith
is the best pizza you've ever had still
found at Tony's Fish Bar in West Lothian
or do you have a new number one slice
from your world um yeah Tony's good also
mad hearing you say that Tony's is great
um shout out Tony's although actually
[__] them because I've showed those
bastards out I lived on the same street
as them and when I was when I was
growing up and never once did I get a
free pie slung Maui so that's not fair
these guys if you're listening
don't where the [__] was my free slices
did you have good garlic mayonnaise I'll
say that but it's great pizza but also I
said [__] you're doing the same boat as
Ed Sheeran Tony's fresh bar
[Music]
I'm [__] ducking on these you're
attacking on them you're attacking on
them baby
I have a thing to show you
that's something
um nothing's got my [__] out it'll be
amazing
we met it's just you you have that sort
of thing no
no but let's chat about it we met in a
nightclub we did what was your name it
was called Delilah shout out to Milo
a lot of ass shaking
I saw just titties right when I walked
in I didn't know I didn't know I didn't
know you could do that and I walked and
I was like this place is not my scene
I feel like
we were both maybe a little bit Fish Out
of Water yeah yeah maybe maybe that
should be maybe you love walking in the
clubs
like when I walked in I was like I saw
peripherally just hands you know and
like excitement yeah so then I look over
and I was like oh do I have some friends
here and I look over and I see uh you
and Niall me Niall Horan and I was so
excited to see Sean Evans I was [__]
buzzing like I [__] love this show
love you you're my cat I love you back
oh you're my taste
I get excited when I see you but I said
to your team you probably don't know
Sean doesn't know me he does his
research of course he's a good man yeah
you were like
I was like one day I hope to come on
you're showing you were like I'm sure
you will and I said but just in case I
don't can you record an intro for me on
my phone yeah and I've still got it you
do yeah
can I play it yeah yeah do it
[Music]
yeah all right so I'm gonna put it here
yeah yeah not that anything's here
yeah
there's nothing right here
um okay
and today we're joined by Louis Capaldi
and you can hear me [__] that was so
buzzing but yeah huge day for me uh and
since all the piles killer saying this
ever happened to me and here we [__]
are here we [__] up halfway through
the way full circle full circle
beautiful
[Music]
okay here we go
basketball
oh yeah
let's hat in a little bit it's getting
real let's get a little bit nippy
maybe I'll slow down on this way it
doesn't look like it oh
that's good there we go we can handle
that I'm getting so scared because I
know what's coming
so I've heard you talk about being
surprised by the success of your song
bruises what do you learn as an artist
when your expectations for a record are
exceeded I'm getting there I'm
salivating and crying
okay [__] you ask me a question I did
I did you [__] Okay it's hot now
[__] you
careful around the eyes careful around
the eyes yeah okay
[__] Jenna Ortega
she can [__] handle away
question yeah it was a good one
thank you you just learned that you
don't know anything because it's like
no one has the answer because it just
shows you that you don't know what a hat
is
thinking this is gonna be a smash it's
been a [__] complete abject [__]
failure
um so yeah you know nothing and labels
know nothing
and like no one knows anything not to no
offense but no one knows anything
it's just like yeah we just kind of I
might come am I visibly crying yeah yeah
but
it's like cinematic and kind of
beautiful it actually is everybody
no one knows anything
for your own Nelson
[__] that's hot no no I'm kind of
chilling out now though yeah but you
know the problem with this show is right
right when it chills out the next bus
pulls up to the station yeah that's um
that's good I'm not gonna wait my face I
want people to see what's the real the
honest the truth
that's what I am
[Music]
oh yeah this one looks innocent
here we go
cheers
really nice at first okay
[__] assume we had your friend now horn
on the show he said that your most
Scottish trait is that you talk too fast
for people to understand you and that he
believes that you do so on purpose
especially when you're talking to
Americans confirm or deny I can confirm
that sometimes I've got friends from
like England who can't understand me but
sometimes I think people are just being
like Oh what are you saying yeah really
right Americans make a more more of an
effort to understand what I'm saying do
you know what I mean yeah winners
English people can sometimes just be
especially polish English people can
just be like
practice for the sake of like you know
what I mean I can't understand the words
you're saying but on the water
I love you England
do you ever go to Celtic FC chant you
know something I can have in my backpack
I should ever find myself
trying to remember oh there's another
thing here can I use this yeah yeah
they're all yours you got the lifelines
over there
Bird Box
that's heating up m
M I don't know there's a really
beautiful song called Grace it's an old
Irish song but it's still different
saying because there's a collection
Island but it's a it's a beautiful tune
as we gathered in the chapel here down
old Kill made in jail I think about
these last few weeks oh my eyes are
I think I've got like a pair of
sunglasses on
that have been in an oven
uh all right here we go I'm really
nervous me too me too I know that's one
[__] yeah and I can hear the editing on
them
music getting higher
reaching fever patch
I was like
what I mean it's happening
life too much yeah that's big
oh [__] you
yeah that's a [__] isn't it
that is a
that's a [__] yeah that was a [__] of
a sauce and you know like on the other
ones they kind of start to build you
know but it takes a while this one
builds so fast and then it just doesn't
stop I said the back of my mouth yeah
it's getting worse and worse and worse
actually it's the devil's a jacket
oh [__] you Sean
it's a little spinner yeah I know I know
yeah yeah so you know I've been
following along with the Press store and
it seems like you're holding on to your
vow to stay on Tinder until the day that
you die what do you think is an
appropriate amount of money to spend on
a first date oh nothing
[Music]
yeah
oh [__] that's good man that's good the
lemonade hitting you you wanted to go
with the citrus
shut up
that's the show
[Music]
there's the thumbnail
I've got a change of Sharp Nobody
oh [__] you I know I know milk
not white milk
and then Lewis this is just gonna be me
this is me being your buddy I know that
the the liquids are helping out
except for it but let's slow it down
just a little bit because sometimes okay
you know when you're mixing hot sauce
and liquids the liquids can become more
of a problem than the hot sauce do you
know what I I let you go to a level and
then once it starts to get a little
dicey it feels like the foundation gets
a little shaky that's when I speak up
right oh
on the other side of it [__] Jenna
Ortega I imagine I mean what's going on
there
what was your questions
appropriate amount of money to spend on
our first date [__] it who cares man you
never maintenance I might never beat
that person again right right right
again
make some sweet sweet [__] love
I am men
who are you again
I feel like I'm talking about like
Austin Butler all of a sudden I'm
nominated for Oscars
so that always happens
and you know what
the more I do this show the easier it is
for me to catch that Hive yeah so now I
float like every episode around this
time it's amazing
oh that one's all right yeah I think
again just because that's the bomb
clears everybody out the pain [__] me
that was good
you got some good content there
always with you families with you
I told you I'd be sweating
so an AI hit by a fake drink kicked off
a lot of discussion and controversy
amongst record labels streamers and
artists do you have an opinion yet on
the proliferation of AI created Music uh
I don't know God that was bad it's like
a second ghost I know I don't care
I mean I do I probably have a more
opinion on it but right now it's hard to
really collect my thoughts
AI just in case
but other rules
and we become its slaves yeah right I
love you baby like your worries about AI
are more in the realm of like sentinent
machine gun mounted robot dogs not
necessarily I'm gonna be [__] by a
machine I feel like right so if they
come up with a song using your voice
then who cares who kills yeah
[__] me good good to be here
thank you so much Lewis just us dabbing
on the last one that's what we're doing
baby that's what we're doing this is oh
I just blew it into my eye oh my gosh
right at the finish line
[Applause]
okay
you don't have to if you don't want to
but it looks like it's going there Jesus
I thought it was gonna be thicker than
that
that's what she said hey
hey yo
[__]
all right what a ride what a ride baby
this has been fun
and I hope to never see you again
I understand
got it tastes nice at first that first
[__] you I don't know one of those and
that was a lot Lewis yeah but don't
worry this one's got a nice long wind up
okay cool
yeah it's a bomb really [__] those
are the vegetable Panic changes the game
changes the game but thankfully our long
overdue dinner date with the wings of
death it's behind us baby to close
things out you've been open about your
struggles with imposter syndrome and
benefiting from the Council of stars
like Elton John and Ed Sheeran
with the heat of a Million Suns coursing
through your veins right now do you have
any foundational advice for people
struggling with feelings of inadequacy
even when their lives are seemingly
otherwise going well bam
that is such a good question
and you asked that the complete wrong
time
and but listen
if you're out there
and you feel inadequate it's probably
just because you are
um
if you're feeling naked imposter and you
shouldn't be able to do the things
you're doing it's probably because you
suck
if you're feeling like
your girlfriend doesn't love you and
she's gonna leave you she probably will
uh you're gonna die alone everybody is
what I'm trying to say to you
oh [__]
um life was meaningless what I'm trying
to say after this I realized
none of this means anything
and then
hell is
awaiting us all this Straight Talk from
Louis Capaldi another dry eye in the
house after that motivational speech and
look at you taking on the wings of death
living to tell the tale now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you this camera this camera
this camera let the people know what you
have going on in your life
I've got an album coming out
as a piece of [__] flaming [__] don't
listen to it but um
please just hit by it I've got a
mortgage now
it's crippling
um so
DG Khaled if you're out there
eat my [__]
um
this was fun
I don't know what else to say
[Applause]
you've got a serious scheme on your
hands here
I'm sorry for swearing at you I was you
know hey going through something I
understand completely you know that was
good fun
here I am feeding you wings with the
bomb what are you gonna do not curse me
up
hey hey look at us look at us who would
have thought Lewis who would have
thought
God me that was [__] great thank you
man
[Music]
thank you so much for watching today's
video I have a very exciting new product
alert last year hot ones brought the
heat to the freezer aisle with our first
ever hot ones boneless chicken bites
well now we are bringing even more heat
to the freezer aisle with our brand new
hot ones chicken strips made with our
first ever seasoned blend two boldly
seasoned varieties you have the spicy
garlic featuring The Classic garlic
Fresno with mild heat and garlic blasted
goodness and Smoky habanero with the
tropical medium spice of our Los
Calientes Rojo we took the sauces that
you know and love and with a little
kitchen magic turned it into the perfect
season blend that go great on our new
hot ones chicken strips to find hot ones
chicken strips near you visit
hotoneschallenge.com that's
hotwingschallenge.com snack em dip them
make them the perfect party platter
[Music]
foreign